Now that you know the basic layout of RStudio,
you're welcome to customize it, by going to Tools, and then
Options. From here you can choose the default directory if you'd
like. You can change formatting options for editing code, or you
can even change the font and the appearance. Here, I'm using
the tomorrow theme, but there are of course some others. You
can also make adjustments to the panes so, feel free to
play around with this to get a configuration that you like.
Now, you might not have any idea what you like first
so just wait until you play with R a bit, and
then you'll find a configuration that suits you. I'm going to
leave this as is. Alright, we've got R set up, so
let's start using the programming language. To get started, I want
you to download the R script from the instructor notes and
open it here. When you open the file, it should look
like this. This R script contains both comments as plain text and
R code. You can run R commands by highlighting a chunk of
the code and then hitting Cmd and Enter on a Mac, Or Ctrl+Enter
on a PC. The lines of text that start with a hash or
a pound symbol are comments. There lines are plain text that we don't
want to run as R code. It's the standalone text that you really want
for the R code. Now, your task is to read through this file
and run and write code when you're prompted to do so. When you
get to the end of the file, you'll get to a question, and
you'll need to answer this question to move on to the next video
in this lesson. Now, if you're already familiar with R, I suggest trying
to answer the questions, and then you might want to go back to the
files to see if you missed anything. We know you learn best by
doing, so it's important that you execute and run this code as you
go, and that you make sense of the output. Any output will appear
down here in the console. I also hope that you have moments of
inspiration. So if something does come to mind I want you to code
it up and just run it in R. You won't break anything and the
worse thing that would happen would be an error message or a warning message
in this box. If you do happen to get stuck at any point post
in the discussions so that way your peers or one of the instructors can help.